[Musique]
brême
lève toi il ya dans mon trio le
personnage de brahim qui est là pour
ramener de l'humour
moi j'en avais contre des clips des
comme ça c'est des vrais présente bright
bright mais en fait c'est un peu le mec
et c'est parce qu'il fait il suit le
mouvement et un implant va élever la
voix même s' il essaye d'aider alors
qu'il enfonce les gens il est toujours
là il est il est présent et il prend la
défense de ses frères à chaque fois
c'est quoi tout ça c'est le gars avec
qui je lui sers mon cousin
c'est bon c'est pas vraiment un cousin
mais ça mon cousin
je connais sa petite serre connaît sa
famille sa mère tenait un petit show net
wind américaine
ouais c'est plus fort qu'elle mêle
qu'ils emmerdent parfois il a des
petites figurante sérieusement c'est là
qu'est la voiture qui arrache le plus à
la plus puissante de tous gardent une
petite chance de génie comme ça qui
effectivement vont germer mon père m et
à inès et à william dedans de ressortir
des grandes stratégies qui vont aider
apache par moments c'est grâce à qui
alors bande de bâtards c'est qu'ils
aient dû faire ma merde faire du buzz
serrure est beaucoup moins avant il a
énormément la danse commence à
s'équilibrer frère j'ai l'impression
d'avoir constamment boulet au pied mais
c'est un boulet que j'aime bien en fait
et j'aurais du mal à vivre sans ce
boulet en fait je suis une grosse merde
romain qui se retrouvent dans la mer
tout le temps tiquer
ces mots à chaque fois que ça se passe
bien eh ben ils arrivent pour ajouter sa
petite touche et tout ce qu as tu vois
mais c'est toujours comme ça c'est cool
c'est très cool de jouer et c'est un
plaisir tu vois c'est un personnage ou
je te tue doit faire rire tu as des
moments tu veux être touchant genre la
docteure je vous parle des personnes qui
me calcule ce sens je pense pour une
merde hein vous continuez donc dire 300
me touche pas je suis en algérie d une
création originale à découvrir en
avant-première en ce moment sur my canal